pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut les copains je pars en vacances
c'est pas la peine de crier comme ça non
ça arrive à tout le monde d'aller en
vacances
et ben moi aimons alcoolique la vie et
dans part en vacances aussi quoi décider
comment quelle coïncidence
elle est coincée c'est pourquoi vous
allez bien vous savez avec un beau temps
comme ça on reste pas à pas alors l'art
plat les grands espaces le soleil les
palmiers les salades des poireaux
qu'est ce que c'est que cet endroit la
fesci webo là c'est comme dirait notre
paradis quoi vous allez
wes commun pousser assez à la à la porte
de montreuil où l'appartement trahi les
envoie moi je prends des vacances à main
prenez ce n'est pas un monde et carlo où
là elle va santé carlo dit à la barre
magique la yougoslavie non ils varient
au goût celui ci
elle va enfin c'est la vie quoi mais oui
la tchécoslovaquie
par chicago comment après à chicago on
en haut en bas âge chic à trois coups
c'est pas parce que j'ai ce prêt par des
voix on a une voiture c'est pas trop
demander de vente et une toute petite
on pouvait même restez comme vous êtes
vous me direz tout et on va vous allez
chercher les voitures je m'en bat
manteau on en parle comme ça je m'en
tiens aux ce que je me disais c'est
embêtant mais s'ils m'avaient fait
bouger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et ça vous en bouche un coin hein
regardez moi ces grandes métropoles et
avec ma
[Musique]
fabrice un papa il ya des moindres à
l'état dans les lacs du chassé
où
ce qu'il est susceptible bizarre cette
voiture comment elle est bizarre c'est
pas normal
vous voulez dire les petits points
l'année c'est parce qu'elles sortent
d'une rougeole oui pourquoi
une quoi est ce que cette année 1,8 ou
non elle a plutôt l'air bête alors faut
voir ça cette à double carbure à ta
soeur
[Musique]
comme ça mes seins enfin les portières
la cha cha et bella bella d'un panier
on s'arrêtera aux abattoirs façon dont
vous allez voir des par les eaux
cherchez la bagnole suis-je bête
il a parlé la fin dida le vendeur il a
dit de la chatouiller
les ouïes du café qu'elle ait fait de
l'effet j'ai changé d'avis je ne pars
plus rendez moi mon chat aller le char
lui le chat la cassure prendre
tu vois bien que je suis et où la messe
et ça c'était bouché tiens à vous dire
voilà les bons coups les deux phrases m7
hermès l'état
[Musique]
ça a marché
à
[Musique]
mais on n'a pas été bien loin
le chat est partout occupes toi de ça je
suis fatigué au haut et où tu vas être
la manif où lé là la manivelle
ah ben je sais pas mais mon dieu mon
dieu mon dieu qu'il est bête
oh oui faut tourner avec sa tante et
retourne en photo au gagnant il y aura
il et les lettrés
économiquement faibles stupide un
individu de stupide invisible 10h abruti
oui je regarde tu prends ça dans la main
comme ça
[Musique]
managua
et le chat j'en ai assez je prends
vraiment le train ma chronique très rare
au sein des ateliers ont bien compris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
obama
rentrée
[Musique]
à mon avis il ya quelque chose qui va
pas y aller
[Musique]
à
on abat
j'ai dit à mon sens un peu du courant
[Musique]
l'allumage
je suis un gunner garder et sabreuses
[Musique]
vous parlez d'une bagnole et
e
[Musique]
oui